Speaker 1: I want to say something to both
the left and right here. At least I want to
address the left and right about something
that I think both sides need to hear,
but for different reasons. If you've been watching
Joe Biden for the last couple of months and I've
covered a ton of the events that Joe Biden has
done, you might have noticed something is up
with Joe Biden's voice and he's had a cough, quite
frankly, for months now. There may have been some
breaks there where it was not a consecutive cough
for the full period of months, but it's been going
on for four months at this point in time. Joe
Biden is the president of the United States, the
president of the United States. Health is a matter
of national security and of global importance.
There is no reason to downplay that. So it's
OK to be wondering. What's up with that cough?
What's up with the strained voice? What is going
on? Biden had a cough months ago and his voice
sounded strained and there were questions then it
may have gone away for a little bit. Maybe not.
It's now back now. The White House says it's
a cold that he got from his grandson. OK, that
may well be true, and it is fine to ask in good
faith what is going on, and to the extent that we
believe the White House is being up front, that's
what it is. And the left shouldn't attack people
asking what is going on with Joe Biden's cough and
voice. I've wondered what's going on. I know many
of you have who commented on it during my streams
with folks who are Joe Biden's age. Sometimes
colds and coughs just can linger for months. It's
completely plausible that that's the explanation.
There's no issue with asking about this or
being worried about it or saying the White
House should be transparent about it now that
that's for those on the left. On the other hand,
there are bad faith actors on the right who are
number one, weaponizing Joe Biden's cough to make
points about COVID policy and other things. And
number two, a lot of those very same people had
no concern at all about Donald Trump's health,
his cognitive health and his physical health
throughout all of Donald Trump's administration.
So let's take it step by step. Biden's cough is
being used to ask questions like the one I'm going
to play for you now, where Fox News reporter Peter
Doocy says to Jen Psaki, Isn't Biden bad for
exposing people by breaking COVID protocol,
by being at work when he still has the cough?
Speaker 2: One more topic to follow up on some
of the questions from earlier. The president
was hoarse and coughing today. A lot of people
in the workforce are encouraged not to go to
work if they are exhibiting those symptoms,
even if they are fully vaccinated. So are
the rules different for the president?
Speaker 3: The president again was tested as
we put out in some in a transparent piece of
information from his doctor, where he received
a response quickly from that test enable him
enabling him to proceed. People also had he
had a cold, which is what you know from the
information put out by the doctor.
Speaker 2: But as you know,
from your own experience, it is possible to
test negative several times before there is
a positive test. So is there any concern
about having him at work while he's got
these symptoms, even if he is showing negative?
Speaker 3: I can assure you that the president
follows every protocol. He wants to keep
everyone safe in the White House, and that's why
obviously we consult with the doctor
and we put out that information to make
it available to all of you. Go ahead.
Speaker 1: OK, so while it is true that
sometimes people test negative for a while and
then they test positive. Joe Biden has no other
symptoms that we know of. He's had this cough
for. If I'm honest, he's had it for months.
Weaponizing it in this way to make it about
COVID protocol is absolute and total B.S. But
more importantly, when Trump seemed to be having
cognitive issues, these very same people said
nothing. They were silent about it. Trump asked,
Where is Rudy Giuliani? When Rudy was sitting
right across the table from Trump? Trump got off.
Air Force One wandered off looking for his limo
had to be brought back by a Secret Service agent.
Trump helped down the ramp at West Point, Trump
glitching when trying to speak, Trump asking about
the oranges of an investigation, and these people
said nothing until he took a dementia test, which
they say, wow, he faced a really difficult test,
which actually isn't difficult when Trump then had
Koven. We knew they were lying. We knew they were
lying about. When did Trump first get it? We knew
they were lying about. When did how sick was Trump
asked. Did Trump need oxygen? Dr. Sean Conley
saying, he's not on oxygen. No, no, no. But did he
need it? Well, I don't want to go backwards. When
did he last test negative? Let's not go to the
past. Let's go to the future. I cared about that,
and I also care about Joe Biden's cough. Biden
having a cough and a strained voice for months is
not great. And I want to know everything there is
to know about it. Leftists should understand that
it's OK to ask about that. But the right wingers
who said nothing about Trump's physical health
during his during his hospital stay and said
nothing about his cognitive health throughout
the presidency are just bad faith actors and we
know exactly what they're doing. We know exactly
why they're doing it. And it is another example
of they claim that these are their principles.
But as soon as the principles are inconvenient,
they abandoned them, and we're going to talk
about that sort of underlying topic next as well.